so on tuesday i started this series of
talks by discussing three problems or
mentioning three problems prime allottee
testing which was a big breakthrough
when it was first given a randomized
algorithm first given anyone even maybe
or equally big breakthrough when a
deterministic polynomial time algorithm
was found paulownia identity testing
which had it almost an equally classical
algorithm and for which we still are
working on d randomizing it and the
circuit a approximation probability
approximation problem so the last one we
were like talking about for the the
other three lectures so maybe we talk
about the polynomial identity testing
problem so the polynomial identity
testing problem is you're given a
circuit that's arithmetic rather than
bouillon meaning the gates are either
inputs say some fixed constants like 0 1
or minus and minus 1 and then e is
either some or multiply previously
computed gates and you can allow
division but it creates complication
because you might be dividing by 0 so
we're just going to ignore that
possibility okay so and this makes sense
over any kind of field maybe even over a
ring if we don't allows Division so
we'll be in particular we looking at it
the version over the integers or over
some fixed finite field find a field of
characteristic p so so the the the
problem is given this kind of circuit in
time you know and the whole the whole
circuit is the input so you're given you
think of measuring size the time of
algorithms
terms of that total number of gates in
the circuit you want to test whether the
polynomial computed by the the circuit
is the identical dentally 0 polynomial
what a couple of subtleties I want to
mention just to get them out of the way
is over the integers this is exactly
what you think it is but over finite fix
finite fields it may not be exactly what
you think it is because a polynomial can
be zero on every point in a finite field
without being the zero polynomial think
of like X to the P minus X mod p bifur
months little theorem that's always 0
over the over the field but it's not the
zero polynomial it's the polynomial X to
the P minus X okay and so you can't
really tell that it's not the zero
polynomial if you're just looking inside
the field but if you go to an extension
field then it becomes non zero okay so
okay so when when in particular that
means when you when you're trying to
test the degree D polynomial you need to
go work over now a field that's bigger
than D so that has at least D plus 1
elements to make it to make it visible
that the polynomial is not 0 and if you
have more than D elements then you're
definitely guaranteed the polynomial has
at most D roots so you'll see some
elements on with on which is non zero
okay so so this question of whether the
polynomial is identically zero is in co
RP has an algorithm with one sided error
where the the errors are only when the
identity is invalid and you think it's
valid yes it's one sided so that puts
the problem in co RP
and this is this algorithm due to a
schwartz ippo the middle and lipton
actually I'm not even sure whether they
have the that any one of those papers
has sort of the full algorithm because
it kind of has if you're testing over
the integers it really has two parts one
is you pick random inputs from a given
range you have to pick it big enough
compared to the size of the circuit okay
but and then what they all show is that
with high probability your the
polynomial evaluated by the circuit
remember we have to work over an
extension field if we don't have enough
points so we have to like pick a number
points that's much bigger than the
maximum possible degree of the circuit
of the function computed by the circuit
and and with high probability the
polynomial at that point is going to be
non zero and that lemma is in all I
think some version of that lemma is in
all the papers but to actually translate
this to a probabilistic algorithm when
you're that's fine when you're working
mod p as long as you have some way of
creating the extension field you have to
talk about that but there are polynomial
time algorithms to create sufficiently
large extension fields but if you're
working over the integers there's one
additional complication and that's that
that when you start multiplying numbers
and you know that circuit can like keep
on squaring them raise them to high
powers square them some more so the
numerical precision might get huge okay
so the numbers might grow our
exponentially long and that's kind of
unavoidable you can write down circuits
where that happens they're even very
simple ones
but the idea then is that you don't
actually need to work completely over
the integers the numbers are large but
not more than exponentially large so if
you pick again a random Prime and you
work mod that random prime if it's
nonzero with high probability will be
non 0 mod that random Prime so the over
the integers the two steps are to pick
random inputs and then pick a random
Prime that's large compared to other
parameters and work mod that Prime
probably like most of you have seen
versions of this before so so that's a
so that actually like puts this problem
you know a lot of the other problems
we're talking we were talking about like
circuit of approximation problem is in
promise PvP because not every instance
you know of the problem you have a
probabilistic algorithm but you don't
have necessarily like a clear
distinction between the accepts and the
rejects when you're doing an
approximation you have like a range of
possibilities that are acceptable and
it's not like a clear-cut boolean
problem this is a clear-cut boolean
problem where there's a clear-cut
boolean probabilistic algorithm that
solves the problem so this problem is
really in co RP not in any kind of fudge
the lines version of a complexity of
probabilistic complexity class and it is
a fairly concrete problem okay although
it is a kind you know so it's a
particular problem info RP is not known
to be seiko RP complete in fact there
aren't any known Co RP complete problems
so so there's no real reason nothing
that really makes this special except
that it's in a form of if you think
about it it beats this format of meta
algorithmic problem or circuit
analysis problem because what we're
given as input is a is an algebraic
circuit and so the intuition is that
somehow solving this problem might
require understanding algebraic circuits
might be connected to understanding
algebraic circuits and so that's what
Valentin and I try to set out actually
that's what we sort of proved I
incidentally um I guess no you know you
okay Valentin actually had the plan and
I was sitting there okay so um
so so can we actually like connect this
problem to proving lower bounds for
circuits say actually it isn't quite
this problem that where the so if you
don't actually like say this part of the
problem is just about numbers it's this
part of the problem that involves
circuit analysis so I'm going to give a
restriction of the problem so that we
can only talk about this part of the
algorithm and D randomizing this part of
the algorithm and not have to worry
about this part of the algorithm and so
now you're going to tell you exactly
what this is but we're going to like
restrict the class of functions that
we're talking about the random I of
polynomial identity testing to be ones
where you this issue a couple of kind of
degenerate issues don't arise first
we're going to make garant by doing this
restriction we're going to guarantee
that the degrees are relatively small in
the second the second condition is is
it's also going to guarantee that the
numbers don't grow hugely thank you but
still it's going to contain a whole a
wide variety of problems
so okay so so we're going to define some
notion of formal degree and formal
degree of an input or a constant this is
this is a little this makes sense this
one dozen we're going to define the
formal degree of a constant to be one
just go with it you should really be 0
but ok but an input has formal degree 1
and then if we have a plus gate the
formal degree of the plus gate is the
maximum of the formal degree of its
implicates and for product 8 is the the
sum so those two make sense see if you
sum up things the maximum possible
degree is the maximum degree of the
things you're subbing multiply is the
sum of the degrees now what we're not it
could be that really there's some
cancellation going on so this formal
degree is only an opera bound on the
actual degree yes giveaway that was your
question a bunch of concepts yeah we're
and we're also like charging 14 formal
degree of constants because what we okay
so the reason is that we want to avoid
these huge numbers of hearing and so we
won't don't want to like generate huge
constants by taking some number like 2
and then squaring in squaring in and
squaring and squaring it and and
counting that as degree 0 because it's
all constant because I would introduce
huge numbers into the picture so that's
like a technical really kind of like a
glitch but this is
yeah just like to find the formal
magnitude of a gate you know inside of
like having dr. rules for that we almost
went with that but so like define a
formal degree in formal magnitude and do
do a simultaneous restriction and I
think that this gives you basically the
maximum of the formal magnitude in the
formal the or weak formal degree or
something like that but this this was
that this was this was in previous work
whereas formal magnitude wasn't yes oh
right yeah / z / so over finite fields
you don't run into this problem you run
into other problems which I'll probably
not not talk about either but why so
over is over finite fields it really
doesn't matter yes although you still
want the video of constants doesn't
matter but the issue of cancellation
taking credit for cancellation still
matters
okay so so we're actually going to look
at rather than the general p IT problem
let's look at to avoid this issue let's
look at the low p IT problem which is
you're given a formula yes you can
compute this low polynomial this formal
degree so the low p IT problem is given
a formula and you're dealing with crying
to be polynomial time in the greater of
the size and the formal degree so this
still has a lot of interesting
applications let me mention one that i
think came up early
and hopefully I'll get this right keep
these complexity classes around oh just
the duplicate we have a spare okay so um
so a branching program is a for
switching network is a kind of simple
computational model hopefully I'm
getting it right we're going to have it
okay 111 format is you have a you view
it as a layered directed graph with
edges going from will say left to right
and then every node is labeled by a
variable and then the two edges are laid
there are two edges coming out of the
node label by true and false
and then some of the some of the end and
states are labeled accepting and
internet you get the definition wrong or
no in some are labeled rejecting it's
like a decision tree with collapse
decision tree with collapse no yeah or
or branching program yeah it's basically
a branching program ranching program
yeah okay yeah anyway so yeah okay so
you can associate with a branching
program so you want to say is there an
accepting state you know is the path
that it this follows an accepting state
and you can just you can actually
compute that as a small degree
polynomial you just sort of like
associate polynomials you know going
backwards in the layers and then you
know the polynomial at this date is P of
S is just x x if x is 0 and cancels this
one cancels this one so
is they should've called professor
so if x is 0 then we evaluate this
polynomial it recursively effects is one
we evaluate this polynomial recursively
and so the see this and you can just
test that this is fitzy algebraic
circuit model okay and so we want to
like so like p of the starting node
tells you exactly gives you a polynomial
plugin which variables are crew tells
you whether this is going to accept or
reject so um so the great but that's not
you know evaluating the branching
program on an input is not so
interesting that's pretty easy to do
what's more interesting is if we give to
branching programs we can use this to
tell whether they're the they're
computing the same function so we make
like a P of the starting state for one p
of the starting state for the other and
then test with the identity is PS equal
to PT and these are multi are hopefully
given that it's read once ya know
variable is parried more than once then
these polynomials will be equal if and
only if the functions are equal and I
think there's no known deterministic way
of testing this hopefully if I got the
problem right but using polynomial
identity testing we're able to do this
and you can see this is these
polynomials are also going to have very
low formal degree
the sad is trivial for branching
programs but equivalence is is only
probabilistic requirements are not
clearly everybody you can't query
variables more than once along a path
yeah
you can query them in different orders
along different paths okay so um okay
so
what we showed is that for this circuit
model of low low degree flow formal
degree circuits or you know some version
of what we showed is that for say over
the integers for for this the problem
poem identity testing for these low
formal degree polynomials is essentially
a door tightly connected with the
problem of proving a circuit lower bound
for the same class of circuits so now I
have to save the where where do we get
our low where are the lower bounds that
correspond to the algorithms remember
that for see a PP the best lower bounds
that correspond it to see a PP
algorithms the algorithms were non
deterministic and the lower bounds were
in an x intercept 0 and X so we're going
to get the the same type of thing so I
could say so if
ok so for like deterministic algorithms
the connections are two lower bounds
with in acts for non deterministic
algorithms so even like showing a
non-deterministic algorithm in the other
non deterministic direction so actually
a witness that the function is
identically zero is non-trivial ok if Co
RP is in co MP so a co ngon turistic
algorithm follows directly from the the
schwartz ippo algorithm ok but so what
we will say so but to like the problem
is you can't actually be this model
doesn't make sense for computing boolean
functions because you you were just
talking about computing polynomials and
the representation of the polynomial
actually matters at least in the finite
field case so so I can't say like is
there an algebraic circuit to compute
satisfiability because that doesn't
really define what pono you know saying
it's satisfiability on boolean inputs
doesn't actually determine which
polynomial I'm talking about so I want
some in order to like say where these
lower bounds are I need to some
canonical way of mapping standard
complexity classes two classes of
polynomials and here's the the standard
way we're going to have like this this
fixed canonical way of mapping problems
in a complexity specific boolean
problems to two polynomials so that
things make sense so if F is a
is a boolean function then there exists
a unique multi linear extension of the
boolean function and this actually came
up beef beef or let's call it f tilde
and f tilde takes in and you know if X
take takes in and boolean inputs f tilde
takes in and it inputs over that our
integers are over the field and compute
something of the form
some mulchen Eric multilinear formula
and it's easy to see that this this
exists in that it's unique and in some
sense this came up before in that it's
really like the version of the
reed-muller Saul Solomon code for the
function so um so when we're talking
about the algebraic complexity of a
boolean function we're really talking
about the algebraic complexity of its
multi linear extension this can get a
little bit nasty in that some classes
are closed under this operation and some
are not and some are sort of closed if
you squint your eyes okay so exponential
time is closed you know you can given
the truth table of the function you can
create this this algebraic
representation of the function as a
multi-linear and they're only
exponentially many coordinates and then
evaluated at any particular point so if
F is a in X then so is f tilde with with
something in I'm also going to be
talking about like an X to intersect
Cohen X when we go to multi linear
extensions and functions in NX dinner
set conex they're essentially in NX
Winterset Cole index in that well NX
vendor said Cohen X isn't you know what
a function being in an x intercept conex
is not really clear because because you
know it has to be it you know what is a
witness that your your to a witness for
two well you say that so we'll say that
that's true if the language you know
what will say is that actually affects
it's we're morally in that in the in the
sense that if F is in NX winterset colon
X and the graph of the function is in an
x-intercept conics well we take it off x
is 0 for 2 1 so x is an input is an
inner you know integer valued input and
this is an integer it's also true over
any finite field
this makes sense so saying morally these
classes are closed under multi linear
extensions and so we can talk about
about algebraic functions with the
algebraic complexity of worst-case
functions in these classes so with that
said
States the result this is some version
of this is from ki but it was done more
carefully using all the provisos that I
just said in a in a paper by Rahul and
get you yeah sorry ki j s and the J is
Jensen okay so in the result is is so
low p IT is
if there exists a function in it and X
so the multi linear extension of that
function is done in algebraic so i
should say like low algebraic p / poly
doesn't have a polynomial size
representation with a with a polynomial
formal degree then / z then low p IT is
in deterministic time g to the end to
the epsilon for every epsilon i should
say you know either this has to be hard
all the time or there's going to be like
an infant lee often and as x-rays what
you go to the FDB i before E and because
i should say f tilde f tilde but thing
so short hand write that as mle is not a
subset this is like should be not
membership and right this is the multi
linear extensions of functions in E are
not in
there's a circuit lower bound for for
that so II what is e or what is e is all
exponential time 22 the order n it could
be like it's equivalent to let go X for
this part so maybe I should do that so
so if we've got a strong enough circuit
lower bound then we've got a d
randomization and in a simile actually
buy the exact same argument if
multilinear extensions of NX bin erst
echoing x are not all in a polynomial
size and formal degree circuits then
the pond oh my getting prepped quest
problem is in non terminal sick time 2
to the N to the epsilon algebraic people
is not right sorry
so if you've got a lower bound then
you've got a better than a non trivial
algorithm for the problem okay and if
the lower bound is in X then it's a
terminus sick one if the lower bound is
for something in NX winners that Cohen X
you get a non-deterministic one and
maybe more surprising we have
connections in the other direction so if
P IT I'm just going to like state it you
know they're like quantitative
trade-offs you can actually get come
close to matching what what the result
this result says but if polynomial
identity testing if flow p I T is NP
then
and then you get the similar the
matching lower bound and actually you
get the same lower bound here if because
we're we're get we're going to a
non-deterministic class you get the same
ol or bound if it's not if it's in NP as
as if it's empty so that says the only
way to de randomized polynomial identity
testing is to actually prove a circuit
lower bound of some kind okay but if you
can prove the circuit lower bound the
algebraic circuit lower bound then you
can then you actually do get an improved
algorithm for polynomial guarantee
testing I would like to point out that
with Marco car Massino Valentin in
antonina we just recently got an
extension to the finite field case so
now that was left open you know in our
original paper but now we know that a
similar connection holds over finite
fields there's one more complication
that I'm not going to mention but but we
get a similar can connect him between
the difficulty of the computational
problem and the difficulty of proving
circuit lower bounds so any any
questions about the statement of the
results sorry it took so there was a
better that said that imagine doing it
even an algebraic for a 40 mm yeah so
this is who I'm trying to like finesse
that so if you so if you this is okay
actually yeah i hear i should also cite
Aaronson and von mel cubic because we're
IM using their argument you can get it
down to NX pinner psycho next and then
you don't have to do the the ugly war
but make sure with this purchase the to
enjoy might want Steve so so this this
is yeah and in the proof you can say
like really the reason why we you know
this is just like the least join of two
things the permanent has large algebraic
proofs of large algebraic circuit
complexity or a problem in at in non
deterministic x-men or said Cohen X has
large boolean circuit complexity but
this sort of the nice join of the two
integer break yeah so saying that sort
of multilinear the algebraic circuits
for multi linear extensions of n x
intercept 0 and X is in algebraic / poly
that implies both NX intersect colon X
is in peace lot is in p / poly is
contained p / poly that that's a
particular boolean question but it and
it also implies that the permanent
function is in algebraic p / public so
like previous versions actually stated
the result as something like this they
either one either this is not true or
this is not true now trying to like make
it a cleaner by going to something
stronger than what we literally need and
but but it's a somewhat cleaner
statement because it's directly going in
terms of algebraic circuits
okay so let me talk about this direction
and if I have time briefly mention how
we do the other direction and it's the
kind of argument that should be familiar
by now it's really like the very similar
to do all the previous arguments with
just 11 twist so the first thing we're
going to do you know so like the
argument for a CA PP was saying c'est CA
p was easy and xpad polynomial size
circuits then first X collapses down to
MA and then ma collapses down to NP and
if X collapses all the way down to NP
then any becomes really hard and in fact
if X quacks is all the way down to NP
it's also be in the NP intersect cohen p
so it's really the hardness goes into an
ex finish that colon x so saying like if
X has small circuits non-determinism
plus randomness is hard you know can do
really amazing things okay randomness
doesn't help you do really amazing
things that it's just non determinism
that helps you do really amazing things
if not in tourism can do really amazing
things then NX must be really hard okay
so that's sort of the same outline will
will do well just have to like go down
to a slightly smaller class than X in
order to work okay and the the class
that will go to and I should it's in the
we're going to is between the polynomial
hierarchy and X you have to add the
class sharpie of counting problems
problems of counting the number of
solutions to say a formula
okay and Toto Toto theorem says that all
of the polynomial hierarchy is contained
and P to the sharpie and the other thing
we'll need about is that valiant showed
that the permanent function is Sharpie
complete so if you put those pieces
together the permanent function is hard
for the entire polynomial time hierarchy
so we're going to work with the
permanent function and say well what if
the permanent function has a small
algebraic circuit what kind of
conclusion can we can we make thank you
so just like in the so let's assume
the permanent is in low algebraic eat /
poly then I'll claim that the permanent
is actually in NP with a low p IT Oracle
so the only thing that's going to
prevent the permanent for being an NP is
if lo is if we can't solve lopey IT and
actually when do you think about it the
argument is almost completely trivial
when you when you work it through so
what do we know about the permanent
there's only one really interesting
thing that we use about the permanent is
it has a nice downward self reduction
now you look at the this is for a minute
of a matrix
over X 1 I of the permanent of the earth
minor the one I've minor where you you
you cross out the first row in the in
the ice column and take the permanent of
the the other matrix for determinate it
has like a minus 1 to the something
permanent permanent is different from
determinate guess because it has no
minus 1 no minus 1 signs and that makes
all the difference ok so but it still
has the same kind of expansion by minors
that you're used to with the determinant
ok and so um and you think of it this
this recursion tells you how to compute
the permanent so any function that
satisfies this recursion at all levels
must must be the permanent so to say
that someone gives us a circuit see and
claims that C computes the permanent
what we're going to do is test using our
low p IT article ok so if c is a is a
low you know algebraic circuit of low
formal degree then we use our OPI t
oracle to test that CEO bays expansion
by miners and that sea of a of a matrix
that's supposed to be one by one his is
X to get us started and if it does then
then then then it must be the permanent
function and it must be the polynomial
and not just computing the permanent
function but it must be the permanent
polynomial if all of these are our
equations as polynomials so
so that's it because if the permanent
really has algebraic small algebraic
circuits that small algebraic circuit
can be the witness and then we verify
that witness using this low p IT Oracle
so if in addition and note this is like
actually we're using this as an Oracle
but we're only it's a truth table
reduction or even a can be made into a
many one reduction mapping reduction so
if this is an NP then the whole process
is in mp so if in addition lope EIT is
an MP and the permanent is an empty and
we said the permanent in NP you know the
permanent is complete for sharpie
permanent MP collapses all of this mess
down to NP in particular can contain
sigma3 p and so when we go i'll go away
up here that hard function that we know
exists collapses down to NX yes just
curious so in testing the that the
expansion it is obeyed so when you also
have to test it within the mark with in
the minors
sorry within them well we have to so
here high beam is shorthand for it obeys
the the miners for n by n and when you
fix the first row to once and the first
column to ones it'll bays the miners for
the USO for the so so the first thing
you do is given a circuit that computes
n by n per minute supposedly commutes n
by n permanent you like can get / get
sub circuits that compute n minus 1 by n
minus 1 and minus 2 by n minus 2 and so
on by just plugging in once at strategic
places you're like plug in 1 all zeros
all zeros then it just becomes the
permit of a 10-1 by n minus 1 matrix
that's sitting here and then you do the
same thing get a minus 2 so when I say
it satisfies expansion of my miners we
really have a family of circuits one for
each size and we're using that's an
equation between the circuit for size n
and the circuit for size n minus 1
Thanks ok or we could be given you know
the sequence of circus because we're
assuming one exists for all links ok so
and actually because Sharpie is closed
under compliment you know this also we
it's easy to just also put it in co MP
for the same reason is this doesn't
quite make sense doesn't match but it's
true anyway so actually we get the
collapse all the way down to and peter
second p which means that this claps
goes down and NS pinterest echoing next
and that's our standard shelf collapse
argument we get this really hard
function in NX finish a conex it's
really hard in the boolean sense right
but
if you think about it for a few seconds
an algebraic circuit for an extension of
a boolean function when you restrict
back to boolean inputs gives you a
boolean circuit for the original
function especially if it's this kind of
low formal degree and you don't have to
worry about huge numbers appearing out
of nowhere okay so that's the whole
argument so well let me conclude so what
we're saying is if both of these things
are true the permanent has small
algebraic circuit and P IT we're in NP
then some other function that's really
hard both for boolean circuits and
algebraic circuits would be an NX
intersect Cohen X so either way we get a
lower bound for an x-intercept colon X
if the if the assuming the the p.i t is
is is easy so either the permanent is
hard that's in this class or some other
problem becomes in this class either way
there's something in this class that's
really hard but you can save a single
problem in the class then yeah it's not
like this class doesn't have complete
problems so I can't like point to any
particular problem I think I think there
are some ways of finessing that but it's
probably not worth getting into a good
well one thing what reason is I've seen
a paper that finesse is that issue but I
don't remember it okay so so let me stop
with the technical part of the talk so
what this says is that but we say this
says that even if we can dear Anne
demise okay let me just give a anecdote
so we actually came up with this
direction before we came up with this
direction and we submitted the paper and
the referee said
well here you're making us really strong
assumption about circuit complexity if
you're just getting a d randomization of
an out of like a standard algorithm we
do randomized standard algorithms all
the time why would you possibly think
that d randomizing this algorithm is
something special that requires this
huge assumption and and so but
fortunately by the time we got that
referee report we had an answer today so
we rewrote the paper and resubmitted it
with better luck but but as the referee
had a good point because we do d
randomized particular algorithms all the
time this is just one particular
algorithm but because it has this meta
algorithmic circuit analysis flavor woo
is actually has a connection to lower a
formal connection to lower bounds so
this is it you know I think it's a
little different because this this you
know see a PP was a complete problem and
so you guys are like expect it to have
some kind of complexity theory component
to it okay p I t as far as we know is
not complete for any natural class okay
so you know that's that's defined in
terms of machine models I should say so
so there wasn't any real reason from
complexity theory point of view a priori
that it should be something special
especially hard to do randomized but
this says that actually in order to
Duran demise it you it's sort of
necessary and sufficient to solve this
long-standing problem of proving
algebraic circuit lower bounds so not
segues into the the open problem that
I'd like to talk about which is we said
p I t is in close isn't complete for any
class on the in the map you know in the
in the hole
zoo of complexity classes well what can
we do when we have a problem that's not
currently classified in our zoo is put
it in a cage and look at it so so let's
define the class of problems that are
equivalent to pee IT and of course p IT
has a probabilistic algorithm so
equivalent must mean under deterministic
algorithms if we define the class of
problems deterministically equivalent to
pee IT we can ask what other problems
rpi t hard or complete and a good
example was a was done recently I think
like shubhangi sheriff was one of the
authors i forget the thing there were a
number of other authors where they
showed polynomial circuit factorization
is equivalent to pee IT under t random
under so this is another problem where
we have a factoring an algebraic circuit
finding the opponent the polynomials
that are factors of it is another
problem where we have probabilistic
algorithms but no good deterministic
algorithms make sure that d randomizing
this is equivalent to the randomizing
polynomial any testing with I think
really the main result is that
polynomial any testing is enough d
randomizing polynomial testing is enough
to demand mice the factory but what
other problems are our polynomial Jenny
testing hard and can we come up with
problems where their randomized
algorithm has a completely different
nature than the polynomial identity
testing algorithm and show that they're
related d randomizing those are related
to two polynomial identity testing let
me tell you one such problem where it
has a kind of possible meta algorithmic
interpretation at least and and I'd like
to find you know if you I think it would
be a really cool result if we could show
that is some version of this problem is
related to D randomizing poem identity
testing and that's on approximating the
volume
of a convex region
until you have like some high
dimensional region in space and you're
trying to like say what is how big is
this region and you like start with like
one point inside this region and you
have some kind of Oracle that will tell
you where whether you're in the region
or not and possibly an Oracle that tells
you if you're outside the region what
direction the region is from from this
by some linear separator so um okay and
so um I think it's like a
people I know who have been working on
it like freeze Kanaan lavash and then I
think that those were the original
people who looked at Mark of Cain
algorithms for this sorry and dire okay
is just like the complete list of
authors or approximately and then there
are other people who have done you know
improvement since the the original work
so it's a very studied problem and uses
the the great method of Monte Carlo
Markov chain two techniques to solve how
is it a meta algorithmic problem well
how you know when you're actually
translating this to a concrete
application you have to translate this
Oracle for the region into some kind of
algorithm that describes the region okay
and so really you can think of this
problem the meta algorithm point of this
problem is you're given some kind of
algebraic circuit that describes the
convex region you know test whether your
point is inside the region or not and
you want to from that algebraic circuit
approximate the volume of the region and
so when my dream was that maybe we could
take a circuit and define a region where
sort of the the dimensions are all the
gates of the circuit there's one
dimension for every gate of the circuit
and we like to find the region where the
the gate is approximately this the right
value given the previous two gates okay
and then sort of and then the final
thing is maybe like a final point is you
know given some some point the last
coordinate has to be less than the
output gate
so that means like if the polynomial is
identically zero then you've got very
little wiggle room in the final output
is only going to be very close to zero
on every input and so this this volume
of this region is going to be incredibly
tiny but if you've got a nonzero element
that lasts you know you still got tiny
dimension in all but one tiny width in
all but one dimension but that last
dimension is going to be whatever the
value of the output is and so the total
volume is going to be much bigger and so
my hope was that approximating the
volume of that region could be related
to polynomial identity testing the
problem is that in general when you do
this the region is not even close to
convex and so there's no Monte Carlo
algorithm to calculate approximate the
volume but the to the general point is
you know maybe that gadget doesn't work
but maybe there's some other gadget that
works for this problem or maybe there's
some other gadget that works for other
kinds of approximate counting problems
and so I'd like to see more more just
and distinct problems that don't seem to
have to do with algebraic circuits be
shown equivalent to polynomial identity
testing or related to polynomial any
testing in in some way what if they drew
just a leak in the air program with
Iranian on the video quality says it is
a genius it's not trivial but i also
don't see how you will be able to give a
reduction from the general palomita I
think sensing problem this algorithm is
the best I think the same algorithm is
the best known but I could be wrong
about that
don't expect that problem to be
reducible to be a team I don't I don't
expect the version where you're
explicitly given the faces of the Regent
to BPI T hard or I wouldn't that would
go against my intuition that this kind
of relationship to circuit complexity
has to do with the problem being some
version of meta of really problem but
but that would mean that if you could do
that it would be even better add even
better result because then you'd have a
problem that didn't look at all like it
had anything to do with circuit
complexity that coded something about
circuit complexity seems like there are
no certificates one way or the other for
the approximate volume so maybe he's
found in that reducible to get into you
you know it's possible but if you but on
the other hand if you have a turing
reduction to 2p IT rather than a many
watt mapping one that also would
preserve having certificates
the Apollo do you have a question or
just